c'est perdu d'avancé
sortir et mon album en cachette rajoute
sam derrière et devine québec
ta mère en qu'athlète je clique gosse
achète on distinct criant mon précieux
si t'as pas confiance en moi tant mieux
parce qu'on a eu lieu devant le dernier
bienvenue vraiment début les scouts
épisodes de 10 et par des gabelles ceci
est l intro la plus énergique du monde
alors contrairement à ce que vous avez
pu voir en début de vidéo mon truc à moi
ce n'est pas le rap mais c'est plutôt
les les chansons paillardes en fait mais
elle gentiment répondeur c'était d'une
vulgarité je suis tout émoustillé bon
bref japon seront plutôt hardcore de la
vidéo d'ailleurs en parlant de musique
je me souviens quand j'étais petit
j'avais un petit rêve un petit peu qui
me tenait à coeur c'était d'être dj
parce que bon quand elle dit j'ai été un
peu la classe ça veut dire que tu
ressembles à sa fin la j'aimerais
tellement et dj
toto bien mais quand même alors pourquoi
ce n'est plus mon rêve parce que tout
simplement quand j'étais petit je veux
un clip à la télévision et je vais en
fait que les dj souvent avait les deux
mains en l'air et là il s'est passé un
petit truc assez incroyable dans ma tête
quoi
ça veut dire que j'ai tout simplement
compris que à dj pouvait se résumer à ça
voici la solution la plus efficace pour
être un super dj jouer sur ordinateur
je lance une chanson
je voulais aussi donné une astuce aux
garçons qu'il regarde cette vidéo oui
oui oui
lorsque vous allez aux toilettes et que
vous êtes en plein repas de famille ou
alors que vous êtes au lycée au collège
ou à l'école primaire ou en interne elle
mais que fais tu devant cette vidéo il
arrive quelquefois que quelques gouttes
ces chèques malheureusement de ce qu'on
appelle notre pays et se retrouve
malencontreusement sur notre pantalon
ben saffi dégueulasse après parce que tu
as l'air de quoi si tu ressens des
toilettes ne vends ton repas de famille
ou de vente et poste et que tu as hâte a
l'air con et bien voici la meilleure
astuce du monde pour contrer ce petit
problème déjà utilisé par 80% d'entre
nous je ne suis pas dans un jeu pc moi
je me suis jamais sûr ça fait une heure
que je me retiens celui va trop me faire
du bien à l'ego % lacombe je mets 3d
glasses bien aux [ __ ] hop us open
je me suis glissé dessus continue qui a
gardé son sang froid entre deux succès
m'a un peu si ton pantalon à gauche à
droite
vite vite merde ça va être suspect après
ferme
c'est une grille tu mort voici la
technique internationale du mali c'est
pisser dessus et les viandes bovines et
stéphane
je suis assez m'en aller au parc astérix
et autant vous dire que j'avais oublié à
quel point les parcs astérix est un peu
parce qu'on imagine
c'est à dire que quand j'y suis allé je
m'imaginais être à la place de ces
personnes à longueur de journée pendant
des heures et des heures en train de
m'éclater comme un fou j'aime d'ailleurs
oblique de toute entente à des personnes
qui double jeu quand ces personnels
double toit des personnes âgées tout le
monde est dans son coin balle écoutons
fillon perd trois places est pas grave
tu bloques l'axé là où cet argent je te
plaît dix minutes d'attentes de perdus
je mettrai aucun témoin j'ai d'ailleurs
vu une personne réagir face à ces fameux
doubleurs et autour dire que je suis
content de faire le maître qui dit rien
le kit est super gentil tu me bloque
l'accès la poussée par un poste-clé tu
le doublé c'est ça se passe de combat ça
moi tu par la boîte à 32 qu'ils ont
passés en touche je te défonce voies ont
pu attend sa voix tu pas parce que moi
aussi j'ai regardé pour abc façon il ya
pas de mal
alors vous savez souvent je traîne sur
le net
bon je me perds un petit peu sur youtube
on appelle ça comme ça on va pas se
mentir ceux qui consiste à regarder
pendant des heures les vidéos les plus
boîte de fuck de youtube et la dernière
fois je suis tombé sur un boxeur qui
avant d'entrer dans le ring cela peut
être un petit peu bon mais qu'il est un
petit peu sûr de lui
mais surpris deux minutes en plus ça
danse ridicule qui fait
et je ne m'attendais pas du tout que
lorsqu'ils montent sur le ring il se
passe ça j'en ai donc conclu le proverbe
suivant qui se la pète ce fait péter
c'était un moment donné il avait excusé
bien capté des parts de gâteau cette
seconde